[Musik]
es ist ganz genau 7 uhr zähne und ich
musste früh aufstehen weil ich gleich
nach münchen
und dann fliegen werden
etliche rocker von amerika weil ich über
die rede
für die entweder aber früher 45 stunden
gegen amerika zusammen mit mindmanager
weiter zwischen schriftführer von köln
münchen das tief der 1050 lud garantie
von münchen war er oder sie weil ich
würde ihm sagen dass ich einen flug als
habe rockenfeller des bag vom fliegen
und wenn man über 1250 kann bis jetzt
glaube ich irgendwie verständlich bevor
nicht auch den weg zum flughafen mit dem
markt mehr fertig beim frühstück besteht
heute einfach aufenthalt die top wenn
ich mir gestern abend noch bestellt hat
und der übrig gebliebene publikum zu
kommen ich habe übrigens vor 13 stunden
[Musik]
ich bin alle kommen münchen und doch
jetzt bescheid kamera vormarsch
aber es ist beim flughafen wird ewig
werde auf jeden fall war es noch jeder
vor dem läuft eigentlich schon komplett
das gleiche und er ist wieder länger als
der arm wiederum eine kamera werden
[Musik]
valuev wieder
wir sind endlich nach einem weltraumflug
und noch mal anderthalb stunden warten
am gate in amerika angekommen ich bin
offiziell
egal jetzt in girlan
er fühlt sich mega gut an für kinder
[Musik]
wir stehen vertraute von flughafen und
das wetter wieder so typische so mega
karte einfach nur sondern ist mit dieser
kamera los ich hab jetzt marco polo
kamera geweckt würde ich hoffe dass
nicht auf cool aber fakt ist
wahrscheinlich alle ausblick diese
fakten film alles klar wir haben hier
haben wir haben wir haben eliminieren
den stuhl auf dem man arbeiten kamen
durch der abbruch von mir und wenn man
will kann man hier in die badewanne
gehen und die städte einfach dass diese
komische kamera die fokussiert das
positive nicht und jetzt gerade geklaut
ich werde nicht alles liegt im übrigen
auf dem flug nicht gefüllt weil er in
einer seiner nachbarn nicht abfangen
heute und andererseits habe ich meine
ganze zeit damit verbracht in welchem
ort wieder mit in komischer städtenamen
zu machen was tust du kannst du aufhören
auch ihr gerade halb europa müssen sie
gegen den jetlag an camp für deutschland
3 wurden nach braucht es gerade die
später 18 uhr und endet am anfang auf
jeden fall werden wir sehr zu einem wir
werden im supermarkt gehen werden was
apple
[Musik]
jahren gemacht habe und ich werde ich
damit ende präsentieren in dem lager
planänderung mit motive kamera ich führe
ab morgen wenn ich mit einer dslr
praktisch dass die abholer wenig für
tolles machen will gesagt der haushalt
bestritten
vor dem fall gerade sind wir gleich
einkaufen gehen und jetzt gerade werden
und nebenbei schauen
deutschland gegen amerika die warburger
freiheit was den salat bestellt und das
viele bürger
auf diesen einfach so viele komische ja
der fokus natürlich am arsch so viele
komische leute unterwegs verhinderten
jemand der irgendwann noch drogen wir
hatten eine folge der kartenflut könnt
ich habe ja eine sim-karte extra hierfür
den usa gekauft und habe jetzt perfekt
ihr bei datenvolumen auf jeden fall
bekommen
wir kochen jetzt wasser wasser wasser
wasser kann mich nur wiederholen die
leute zu bestrafen sondern altertümer
mitmacht oder regale kamping vom typ an
mit iphone und hat und so die ganze zeit
zu gefällt einfach zu weit so weit aber
dreht seinen die situation immer noch
gefüllt hat was ist mit euch jeder in
dieser verdammten stadt damit auf drogen
oder komplett vertreten und diese kaka
mit der kamera zur gewohnheit also jetzt
guckt jetzt geht wieder und wenn ich
dinge wieder so mache dann ich geb dir
wieder zwei sekunden wieder kaputt
wir sind in unserem hotel angekommen
dass ihr mich ja schon gezeigt also
house alles klar gewesen folgert einfach
zu 40.000 flaschen gekauft weil wasser
braucht menschen zu
das aber ist nicht schön aber es wird
ganz cool auf jeden fall werden wir uns
jetzt wieder ein hotelzimmer gegeben und
wir sind jetzt wieder im hotel
angekommen und jetzt werde ich euch die
wortspiele zeigen die ich im flieger mit
den komischen städten wie beschreibt man
eine prostituierte hitze hof in welcher
stadt bezahlt man nie den vollen preis
rabattvertrag der wettermann wenn der
schnee verschwinden wird in welcher
staates schutzkleidung beim
fahrradfahren pflicht
helmstedt kennst du diese neue dumme
ideen zucker sprachlos was alles was
sagt jemand auf dieser sprache wenn er
nach beim auto gefragt wird am ford in
welcher stadt solltest du eigentlich
leben und ihr ja wenn du dann endlich
ausgepackt und bist darfst du dort sogar
einem seelenleben wo gehst du hin weißt
du wie der see heißt groß sklaven sehen
dass wir irgendwie noch 78 andere worte
aufgeschrieben während zwei stunden
später gegen die langeweile hatte und ja
wie gesagt wird auf jeden fall wieder
auf hotels und ihr gemacht warum helfe
wir sind irgendwie tatsächlich krank
geworden oder sind halt irgendwie amt
von dem zwölf stunden flug und genau
deswegen
wir gucken jetzt auf jeden fall noch die
feine hier zu ende
nba spieler mal gegeneinander dieser
blog hier gefallen hat er das gerne mal
zeit mit becker hat zu den ganzen tag im
flieger saßen wir sehen uns dann denke
ich morgen im block wieder
bis dahin würde ich sagen
[Musik]